Mr Texas himself we're in Bay City
godamn it be careful with that house be
careful with that house we're at his n's
house I'm in a t-shirt this is my nanny
right here so this is my grandma my
dad's mama when my mother passed this is
what I came to live with and I lived
with her in Bay City forever how proud
of you this guy right now I am very
proud of him he is one of my precious
jewels in my life uh Virgil was a
challenge growingup and he is a
wonderful Challenge and a beautiful
blessing to you guys thank you for your
support I am so proud of him was he
rapping like would you hear him rapping
oh my goodness let me tell you Virgil
has his books he has been rapping since
he could talk first langage I gave him
his little books he had that he would
write sometime he started off with
drawing pictures of his songs and then
he started asking me how do you spell
this nanny how do you spell that and
then he started writing his own little
songs and all of those little books I
saved them and I gave them back to him
when he signed his contract wow but he
has been rapping since he was since he
could
talk wow yes since he could talk
upstairs my room upstairs everywhere
everywhere we went I have people tell me
all the time all the time here in Bay
City and surrounding towns everywhere we
went can I wrap you a song can I wrap
you a song and I'd say Virgil not right
now were you rapping your own [__] or
were you trying to rap other people's
[__] oh no his own stuff yeah I
definitely had my own stuff but I
remember I remember like you know
mimicking eight miles rap battles 8 m
yeah definitely yes he would and and so
I would go shopping and he would
entertain all the ladies always did your
grandson come in with you and I'd say
yes and they already knew he's going to
be around singing him a song p Royal all
that P Royal all the pet Royal workers
if they see this they're going to say
that's the boy that sang to us they say
he used to shoot cows in the backyard
did you know about that yes I did with
the airsoft guns the airsoft guns the
judge owns the property right behind us
so you guys you just just annoy the cows
a little back there we did we were mean
though
yeah yes he would uh you know the cows
come from way over there all the way
around here this used to be the old
airport uh in Bay City so now the judge
owns it and all of this property he has
cattle cuz they own like from way over
there all the way around you you had
mentioned when your mom passed away that
you were you there was opportunity for
you to go live in Arizona with your best
friend I was my your cousin your cousin
his which is her daughter Leslie okay my
daughter that's where his mom wanted
that's where his mom wanted him to go
live micophone how how I'm going say how
how how different would everything have
been if you would I have been a square
yeah you might not be here no I wouldn't
be who I am you you'd you'd be seeing
drton again I'd be Dron You' be you be
you be in the military very very strict
yeah definitely but even even even as a
kid though like Dron denon's always been
grown like he's like he's always he's
always planned ahead his mentality was
just like always mature like
hey talking about you bro I have I have
nicknames for all of my grandkids and
just talking about how if he wouldn't
live with you when he was a kid he'd be
a square yeah probably I'm not I'm not
too bit of a I'm not spontaneous cuz
this is your cousin who's a how many
years you in a bad [__] though
uh just four in the military which which
branch in the Army yeah this guy this
guy's that's got a hero right here
medical medical medical field and now
he's going to continue he was he was a
he was a badass bull rider too yes he
was bull riding bu rider that's [__]
that's Yellowstone right there man
that's a cowboy right there his friends
he was bull riding with became
professional when he opted to go to the
military so this is the crib huh yeah
and like I and like I said a lot of this
used to not be like this you know like
there was a tree right there that was
viro's tree what I learned how to do off
of that tree he would he would run up
the tree all the way up like three or
four steps and then flip all do a back
flip and he'd say Nanny come and film me
that's because he'd be setting the phone
to fil have you seen footage of him
doing back flips on stage in cowboy
boots oh yes I have seen make sure
you've seen it worry about that we're a
little bit happier now yeah for sure hey
eating is good yeah eating is good I was
telling him about Richard too about
remember remember his his damn obstacle
yeah he was a monster bro like bro but
like that thing that thing was like good
20 25t in the air you know neighbor had
like a straight American Ninja Warrior
set up because that's what he did and so
his whole backyard he had it completely
set up and Virgil would always say he
ever he always and I saw Nelly today for
the last hour and a half talking at HB
wow and and if she sees this interview
she's GNA cry yeah so so I had a buddy
named Curtis and he lived across the
street and uh you know I was how old was
I when I first moved to everybody like
10 maybe nine my mom di when I was eight
so 8 nine 10 he was uh and I had a buddy
named Curtis and the Curtis was like
what he was about 30 at the time 30 see
I always some out with kids older than
me even just people older than me and um
and I remember I'd go over there all the
time we'd be play Mortal Kombat I
remember those videos were going
somebody was dressing up as a bunny and
like beating people up you know what I'm
saying that that was going crazy and uh
he he had a hot tub back there he used
to have you know some hot ass girls come
over and [__] and one time as a kid he
was like you know like you scrub my
whole porch I'll get you a pizza you
know he was like a big bro to me you
know what I'm saying just cool as [__]
he cut hair he wasn't no gangster or
nothing like that either just just a old
older cat and you know he [__] with me
and you know and Curtis was cool he
passed away though a while back damn
yeah they just found him like L laid
down just in his throw up yeah but RP RP
the Curtis definitely Curtis was a
[__] gangster I [__]
with Curtis yeah right pops did you just
get a pump in did
you just came out with a shirt off no
pushups in the house and then my popping
really really my popping the bad
[__] you need to talk to Popp
this this is poppin Poppin come here you
know what without popping in our lives
yes trying to get come on man pop come
here this that boy right here the this
the blue strap you got to get in here
man you see what I'm wearing well that's
you that that's your that's your label
bro you look [__]
amazing she knows how to get you on
screen yeah yeah yeah we just want the
audio man he's a bad [__] though
like what about this guy with the great
taco
shirt oh he's a neighbor down the street
no but you got to understand though my
popping you know what I'm saying like
you know he we you know my my Bop was
around but you know him and my nanny
separated so I had my Popp in and man
bro he was definitely a bad [__]
that I needed in my life tell you what
for sure it was just and bro the fact
like cuz he didn't have to take her in
especially me cuz I was already coming
with her and that's like a that's a
whole different headache I ain't got
nothing to do with him so like you know
for him taking me in and still loving
her and loving me and and you know just
holding it down for us I was going to
leave him to move out and get my own
place because since day one Virgil was
born he was always my responsibility wow
I made sure he had his school clothes I
made sure he had even even when my mama
was alive like every Friday she was at
my school volunteering that's dope you
know and so I would go to his school and
volunteer and he um Pete said no you're
not going anywhere I want you to stay
here we will raise him and so uh yes
without there he is come on man come
over here bro I'm trying say he's a hero
bro he's got you're you're you're a hero
around
[Laughter]
here he said
I here it comes popping commit so man I
always talk highly of you Poppin so look
you got to get in here man this is him
right here man you're him you're him
Duncan this is Mr him right here a lot a
lot of the traits that I have a lot of
just greatness that I have in me came
from this man right here you know like I
said like he didn't have to [__] take
us in and and you know I have no blood
from him and [__] and he loved us like
like we were his was it like having this
kid in the house growing up [__] well
you know what um it's all about family
yeah love ain't got nothing to do with
it yeah family looks out for family yeah
and when it comes to Pete it my kids are
like his kids for sure and and uh his
kids are like my kids and our grandkids
they know him more as a grandfather my
Poppin that's what that's what we call
call him Poppin it's Poppin and and his
oldest grandson which is he was born
right before drton Mason shout out Mason
Mas son Rodriguez he's a wonderful guy
yeah he's amazing too and uh so um yeah
they all grew up together wow that's
dope man L ball he put us through school
and all that you know yeah Popp ran up
like a band in
porn did he tell you that story what
story popping got to tell you that what
happened which one the one when you got
that all that money charged on you were
riding up the internet porn on his card
bro was CRA hey my dad picked me up took
me to Austin right I'm getting a haircut
my dad's like go ahead son tell him what
you did you know proud of it and [__]
tell tell him eating that [__] up
laughing I'm like
bro what website was it you you remember
Ron White you know who around why is
yeah the the the comedian comedi the
comedian salad T that one you know how
he's got the part of his stand up he's
talking about his track record and and
the man satellites are linking up you
know
just that's kind of what my AT&T bill
was like that one
M where where you wait what you doing
bik watching T he was watching oh you
were buying it he was buying online
watching and I asked him what you what
do you do you got so many of them in
just one month he said well i' started
and it would I didn't like it so I'd go
to the next
one hey he had a busy a busy uh busy yes
he did you guys probably ran out of
lotion bottles too God damn bro my hey
my nanny telling my p i wondering why he
started sleeping with his door
closed we didn't we didn't know why it
was 45 many showers yeah I'm
like so long and I'd say come down here
I'm going to and he come downstairs and
I when I tell my grandkids to shampoo
your hair twice I mean it so he was
going through a lot of shampoo oh yes
but his hair but it wasn't on his
head so I'd say you go upstairs get in
that shower again and shampoo your hair
and I'm like sweetie what does he do up
there for an hour you knew he said
sweetie he knew he knew if it's anything
about what it was like when my boys were
growing up I don't even want disgusting
I bet your pops was going through all
kinds of shampoo it was probably close
they had they had wikipedias though like
you know I had I got your dad was in the
magazine era right [__] yes I was
behind pictures like yeah when I clean
I'd clean behind pictures I take them
down and these magazines fell down and
it's like oh my God wait wa you would
you would stash pornos behind the
pictures my little brother doing this
yes I wonder what you have to say hey I
[__] one day one day we're moving on
my bed like I'm living with him one time
and we're moving on my [__] and [__]
we lift the bed up and he was like hey
I've been wondering where the [__] that
[Laughter]
went damn no but yeah anyways so this is
the house you grew up in man popping in
nny yeah this is who I was with for a
long time he likes to come he says nanny
I like to come and
just we all we all came here to poop
it's really what happened
Danny I got a and it's like 50 yeah go
bleep that out dude I
remember thank you you just put it out
there for the
world don't give him an address please
no we're good of course not of course
not dude I remember I remember it being
like 3:00 in the morning and my nanny
would be waking me up for school and I
remember she'd be putting everything in
the in the trunk getting me ready to
take me to my babysitters and I man just
being cold and you know I sit there
think of it now and it's like dude they
was it was was putting in at work yeah
put not coming home till 6:00 at night
and then dealing with my punk ass boy
they was putting in at work man for sure
for sure my creativity also came from my
nanny a lot cuz like even in elementary
every every project we had I was always
getting best project cuz like cuz you
would help yeah that's that's how my
wife is our kids like every time there's
a project it's like make they show out
yeah for sure we was always doing some
crazy stuff so I'm also grateful for
that too like my creativity went far
kids Adel Adel school they don't know
who their parent his parents are that's
and bro there like man she even our
clothes like she grew up making a my
dad's clothes making costumes for us and
stuff like that there's a shirt there's
a picture I had posted on Instagram of
me and Bushwick and we're matching
another one for you right now yeah we
were matching outfit she made that shirt
in the the outfit for my dog I got
another one out there laid out that's
what I was shwing on earlier today my
dad was thinking that they had money
growing up but you know they were poor
but they thought they had money cuz like
everything was just built so well you
know making it right that's fire right
that's that's good [__] that's good yeah
anyways ble Kevin Bay City Texas man